I received my model of clear hist and clear CV today and see that they both been reformulated.
Can you tell me about the changes in why they were done?
So the clear CV we wanted to add vitamin A to it because the synergistic effects of
those things for clear CV to help with with colds and viruses was just missing vitamin A.
So we switched it to add vitamin A. So that's really the only difference in clear CV.
The clear hist formula is a little bit different because we just went to we switched to a
different company with that that I was happier with with the total product itself. So the clear
hist there's more it's a similar product but there's more changes to it. I just think it's a much
better product. We're always just searching to get to give you the best products especially
products that have our names on it. We want the best product out there.